Today we started off by discussing
the goals, outcomes, and
learning strategies for this class.
That led us into discussing the project,
the main assessment in this class.
The project builds on Raven's
Progressive Matrices, an apocryphal
human intelligence test, an idea
called computational psychometrics,
the application of computer models
to understanding human cognition.
We then discuss the seven main
principles of CS7637 that are going to
come up again and again in this course.
We recommend you keep and eye out for
them because they'll come
up in every single lesson.
This is the end of the introduction
to this course, so
we hope you're excited to get started.
We're going to start off with
the fundamentals of knowledge based AI,
including one of the most fundamental
knowledge structures called
semantic networks.